y se ha ampliado el Medicaid para niños.
Llevamos décadas intentando reformar el sistema de bienestar infantil
y este año hemos conseguido por fin un gran avance,
el tener preparadas las propuestas para cuando llegue el momento del cambio;
a veces lleva cinco, diez o veinte años, pero seguimos ahí.
He intentado mantener a los niños fuera del cuidado tutelar e instituciones,
con sus familias y con servicios preventivos.
Eso se aprobó.
Pero hay millones de niños que tienen esperanza
y acceso a educación en la primera infancia.
Todavía no hemos terminado, y no vamos a sentir que hemos terminado
hasta que acabemos con la pobreza infantil en el país más rico del mundo.
Es ridículo que tengamos que pedir eso.
(Aplausos)
PM: Hay muchos problemas, a pesar de los logros,
y gracias por haber mencionado algunos de esos logros:
los colegios libres,
las generaciones de niños beneficiados por el programa del "Children's Defense Fund".
Pero, cuando observas el mundo, tanto a este país como a otros países,
siguen habiendo muchos problemas.
¿Qué es lo que más le preocupa?
MWE: Me preocupa lo irresponsables que hemos sido los adultos con poder
a la hora de legar una tierra más sana.
Y me preocupa cuando leo el "Boletín de Científicos Atómicos"
y declara que, a día de hoy, estamos "a dos minutos de la medianoche".
El minutero ha avanzado.
Hemos puesto nuestro futuro,
y el futuro y la seguridad de nuestros hijos, en riesgo
en un mundo que todavía sigue muy dominado por la violencia.
Tenemos que acabar con eso.
Tenemos que dejar de invertir en guerras e invertir en los jóvenes y la paz
y estamos muy lejos de conseguirlo.
(Aplausos)
Y no quiero que mis nietos
tengan que librar esas batallas de nuevo, así que cada vez soy más radical.
Cuanto más mayor me hago, más radical me vuelvo,
porque hay cosas que, como adultos,
tenemos que hacer por las generaciones futuras.
Y vi los sacrificios de la Sra. Hamer y de toda esa gente en Misisipi
que arriesgaron sus vidas para mejorar las nuestras.
Pero EE.UU. tiene que asumir su fracaso a la hora de invertir en los niños;
es el talón de Aquiles de este país.
¿Cómo puede ser que una de las mayores economías del mundo
permita que 13,2 millones de niños vivan en la pobreza,
o no tengan casa,
cuando tiene recursos para proveer por ello?
Tenemos que reflexionar sobre quiénes somos como personas
y ser un ejemplo para el mundo.
No debería haber pobreza,
de hecho, si queremos acabar con la pobreza en el mundo,
debemos empezar aquí.
Hemos progresado mucho pero es un trabajo muy duro,
y va a ser nuestro talón de Aquiles.
Deberíamos dejar de recortar los impuestos a multimillonarios,
en vez de a los niños y su atención médica.
Deberíamos tener claras nuestras prioridades.
(Aplausos)
Eso no está bien y no es rentable.
Lo fundamental para este país va a ser educar a la población infantil,
todavía hay muchos niños que no saben leer ni escribir a un nivel básico.
Estamos invirtiendo en las causas equivocadas,
y no me molestaría que alguien tuviera mil, o 10 mil millones de dólares,
si no hubiera niños hambrientos,
si no hubiera niños sin hogar,
si no hubiera niños sin educación.
Todo gira en torno al sentido de la vida y a lo que significa vivir.
¿Para qué estamos en el mundo?
Estamos en el mundo para mejorar las cosas para las generaciones futuras.
Nos preocupa el cambio climático y el calentamiento global,
y lo vuelvo a citar: sigo cada año el "Boletín de Científicos Atómicos"
que está a día de hoy "a dos minutos de la medianoche".
¿Es una locura el querer dejar un mundo mejor a nuestros hijos?
Ese es nuestro propósito, dejar un mundo mejor para todos,
y el concepto de que haya suficiente para todos.
No debería haber niños hambrientos en el mundo
con la riqueza que tenemos.
Así que no se me ocurre una causa mejor.
Creo que me guía mi fe y ha sido un privilegio servir,
pero siempre tuve los mejores modelos a seguir.
Mi padre siempre decía que Dios dirige una economía de pleno empleo,
y que, si sigues la necesidad, siempre tendrás un propósito en la vida.
Fui testigo de su compenetración con mi madre, que era su aliada,
siempre supe que era, como mínimo, tan lista como mis hermanos,
y siempre supimos que no solo se trataba de nosotros,
sino que estábamos aquí para servir.
PM: Marian, quiero decir, en nombre de todos los niños del mundo,
gracias por tu pasión, por tu tenacidad y por tu defensa.
(Aplausos)